mais t'es sûr je vais pas me dire après
mais je suis pas obligé enfin c'est
juste un anniversaire donc fred elle
peut comprendre
bon ben c'est bon on va pas s'empêcher
de vivre quoi et le gynéco là il a dit
oui huitième mois il faut être prêt de
votre femme est pas couché tout moment
mais ben tu vas partir à peine une heure
c'est beaucoup moins une heure bon elles
le seront jusqu'à 3 1
ok s'il vous plaît les gars
concentrez-vous alors j'explique
rapidement un principe de ces 20 km
c'est simple il va falloir en sortir
ap ap après les téléphones sont attendus
dans la salle ok merci non mais ma
copine et aux synthés là on approche du
tome donc il faut que je garde à
proximité dans tu mets ton tu es tu mets
ton téléphone en mode cloud et en cas
pas de souci on va le mettre en mode
avion vous êtes prêts avec 3 2 1 en
entrant dans cette pièce vous avez été
projeté dans le futur
vous avez pris les traits les couloirs
du temps et des regrets aux s'il vous
plaît on va pas le copain là je vous ai
vidé dans nos téléphones et main perdu
les eaux vous pouvez ouvrir s'il vous
plaît ma copine va accoucher
regardez bien autour de vous je peux
vous donner un indice
l'union fait la force les conquois aux
rays doit sortir en fait c'est pas le
jeu est beau il est un indice on se
concentre tout est fermé
vous êtes ici car vous êtes un père
absent vous avez raté la naissance de
votre enfant
dépêchez vous avant de rater toutes les
autres étapes importantes de sa vie
on va regarder baba papa qu'est ce que
tu fous là je rate à polytechnique
je n'étais pas là pour mon pote
[Musique]
ainsi qu'un berger ben [ __ ] mais ça
aurait été cool que tu sois mon mariage
non franchement tour a quand même pu
aller à son mariage quoi venez voir
venez voir avant de partir jour un
message à passer c'est pour mon père peu
notre temps je l'attends du mais
maintenant je sais qu'il viendra pas
papa si tu me cherches je suis sur mars
aléa plus est les gars c'est une lettre
cher peuple
bientôt mourir n'a jamais été la
probable je pourrais tout bête tout
jeter attends je sais il faudrait la
première lettre de chaque mot l'inversé
avec celle du nantes
la coup dur dernière l'étoile à
apprendre des plombes avec vous
[Musique]
c'est acquis
le ne pas paniquer bouge pas
[Musique]
bon
les actions valent un speedo spitzer et
hop
vingt-sept minutes 14 secondes super ça
veut dire qu'il nous restons à la
maternité la boule noire est super drôle
mais non je suis désolé on joue peu à
pierre et le loup comme celle ci c'est
parce que j'ai vécu le nom quand est
anormal
[Musique]